i'm uh i'm a role model
there may be the gold standard of pop
culture fandom
i do own every episode of the original
series
trekkies devoted fans of all things star
trek
i'm a bit of aficionado there here's how
this community became
so important to the franchise's legacy
i'm a big fan of the show
and good answer i am big fan
after the original series was cancelled
in 1969
it was the passion of star trek fans
that reignited gene roddenberry's
universe
we have an audience that's very very
loyal
trekkies have played a crucial role in
the franchise ever since
occasionally you get questions or
responses which are
a little unexpected the popularity of
star trek conventions led to the events
reaching an iconic status of their own
for instance a young man stood up he was
i suppose about 15.
nice looking and uh he stood up and he
said
mr stewart i i don't have a question i i
have a request
please would you marry my mother and uh
and
occasionally the unexpected like that
will occur of course i declined as you
can well imagine
they're so loyal and they're so warm and
they're uh
very supportive and that's the reason to
come to these conventions is because
this is the only time that we get to
meet the fans more than on a one-on-one
basis
i go to the star trek conventions and i
have 14 year old boys
come up to me and say that i'm their
favorite character
that's huge that's a huge thing as the
star trek world expanded through the
decades
trekkies have always been first to roll
out the welcome mat
i was getting fan mail before the show
even started shooting
we haven't even seen it yet and we're
just part of the family straight up
straight away so
it's incredible let's make some noise
what we strive to do from the beginning
is uh
try to attract new viewers to the to the
franchise but
also uh pay tribute to what's gone
before and to give the trek fans who are
near and dear to our hearts something to
look forward to celebs are fans too
from politicians to pop stars it just
took me
one episode to fall in love with this
other world that i couldn't understand
but i felt like i could relate to
the fans are so wonderful and they're so
perceptive and
they come in every size and shape and
color
and age from about five to ninety five
in star trek's newest era it's more
evident than ever that trekkies are why
the franchise has endured for over
50 years you know it's it's you know no
surprise to us but obviously the
continued dedication and loyalty of star
trek fans
is something that you know made star
trek survive
people are really starting to share
their stories of what star trek has
meant to them over the years
and how much it's going to mean to them
now with all the crazy things going on
in the world
while star trek fan events have been put
on hold during quarantine
jerry o'connell has given trekkies
something to look forward to at the next
convention
let's do this so look i will say this
you will be
once all the cons open up again and
we're allowed to do it
you will be seeing my wife and i in full
number one
starfleet here we're gonna look real
good
we're gonna get it tailored it's gonna
be tight in all the right places
hey you live long and prosper okay